let's talk now though about some of the
Republicans who are absolutely bailing
on Donald Trump because of those
horrifying lewd and classless leaked
audio tapes let's first talk about House
Speaker Paul Ryan uh Paul Ryan
immediately after the leaked audio tape
with the billy bush broke we r donald
trump talks about [ __ ] grabbing asked
Donald Trump not to attend a campaign
event with them as a whole bunch of
other Republicans also tried to distance
themselves Paul Ryan Donald Trump where
were expected to appear together in
Wisconsin and uh Paul Ryan announced
that Trump would not be appearing with
him I think we can all figure out what
is going on Utah Republican governor
gary Herbert said he can no longer
support Donald Trump Utah Republican
congressman jason Chaffetz has also
rescinded his endorsement of Donald
Trump Virginia Republican congresswoman
barbara comstock and Colorado
Congressman Mike Coffman have called for
Donald Trump to step aside all together
and for Mike Pence to lead the ticket
Republican Utah Senator Mike Lee called
on Donald Trump to resign here's a tweet
from Senator Mark Kirk of Illinois who
is running an uphill reelection race
saying Donald J Trump is a malignant
clown unprepared and unfit to be
President of the United States Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell said
that the comments are repugnant and
unacceptable in any circumstance let's
go to a tweet from Mitt Romney the 2012
Republican nominee uh who has been
critical of Trump saying hitting on
married women condoning assault such
vile degradation demean our wives and
daughters and corrupt America's face to
the world what about former Republican
presidential candidate Senator Marco
Rubio he's not happy either tweeting
that Donald's comments were vulgar
egregious and impossible to justify no
one should ever talk about any woman in
those terms even in private and then
john mccain arizona republican senator
john mccain who Trump said is not a hero
because he was captured and was a
prisoner of war saying but Donald
Trump's behavior this week concluding
with the disclosure of his demeaning
comments about women and his boasts
about sexual assaults make it impossible
to continue to offer
conditional support for his candidacy
Cindy with her strong background in
human rights in respect for women fully
agrees with me in this Cindy and I will
not vote for Donald Trump I have never
voted for a Democratic presidential
candidate and we will not vote for
Hillary Clinton we will write in the
name of some good conservative
Republican who is qualified to be
President and Jon Huntsman the former
governor of Utah ran for president as a
Republican in 2012 called on Donald
Trump to withdraw from the race all
together uh well it's crazy you grab a
few [ __ ] and nobody wants to shake
your hand er stand next to you all of a
sudden a new york times reporter phoned
into the Rachel Maddow Show and said
that there are preparations being made
for Donald Trump stepping down although
Donald Trump said completely
unequivocally that he is not stepping
down what we do know has already
happened is that the Republican National
Committee has stopped at least some
financial support of Donald Trump there
was an internal email obtained by
Politico that was leaked from Republican
National Committee staffer Lauren to me
who said stop all spending related to
the victory campaign this is a campaign
that does Mael projects primarily but
also other stuff for the Republican
nominee saying in the subject line quote
hold all projects this is a key project
for helping Trump win the election uh
this is bad this is really really bad
for Donald Trump unprecedented in some
ways and we will see what ultimately
happens I have new polling for you later
in the show and Republicans are jumping
ship like we have not seen before from
an official presidential nominee I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone oh
the phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each CarShare member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David